we just enter he had comedy writers
Peter des Berg and Jeffrey Davis of show
me the fun
we asked them about people that plow
through difficulties you seem like
you're always upbeat in a great place
what do you do when things do get
difficult whether it's hard drive
crashes something and it's very very
frustrating how do you yourself out of
that what we do because they said that
successful people just keep going right
that's one of the secrets right it's
very true i have a good support system
my wife Suzie I have good friends in the
business good filmmaker friends and
actor friends that you know I think all
of them can offer me different pieces of
advice or just support when I need to
hear those words about you know keep it
up keep going you got to keep going
and I think that's what it is it's just
having surrounding yourself with people
that believe in you and someone you
respect and Trust too so it's not like
someone who you know it's someone who
kind of inspires you and when they're
telling you these things you believe it
because you look up to them that really
helps so you reach outward instead
pretty much yeah in terms of like hope
we get my computer died this year so
last year and yeah I don't think I
reached within to try to find okay so
I'm gonna talk to somebody about it sure
but yeah I mean definitely like within
its half happen to be if you're looking
within I think it has to be a certain
type of just knowing that your will be
dark times and you'll have to get
through it because there's always that
point the point where you come you break
through it because of something else
some other good news like it's not just
bad news all the time unless you're in a
Charles Dickens novel take
or something you know where there's
nothing in the world is so bad you're
making movies you know I mean how bad is
your life if it's you're making movies
you know and it's something about your
movie you know it's not like you know
some total hardship about something else
I can understand being depressed if it's
something else but if it's your own
movie then you know there's there's ways
getting rounded there's there's other
bright sides that you can look at from
another perspective but if someone has
low frustration tolerance we're gonna
throw us like a logical right and then
they just they're frustrated at the
process sometimes what do you recommend
that those people take a walk turn on
something funny
I love it I love hot chocolate have a
jameson right and yeah anything that
makes you happy and distracts you you
know watch a movie for me it's hanging
out with friends it's definitely
watching other things to get you back
and getting inspired again to you know I
for me it's funny because anything i
watch i was just get jealous in a good
way like man like i just want to make
something like that you know and it gets
you fired up to go back into that to
that man cave my man cave and work
harder and better to trot it you know
even if you are in a funk you know and
and that's something for me that's why I
have so many projects going because if
there's something you getting down about
if you have writer's block or something
you know you have you know ten of the
things that you're juggling any way to
keep you busy or keep your mind
distraction on something else jealousy
is an interesting thing I know the marc
maron podcast he's been very open about
talking about
resented other actors for their success
or whatever was and then once he finally
had the podcast that he did he came to
see that Wow it was just I did paid them
it was the fact that I didn't he I I
hated where I was so what do you say to
other actors filmmakers that somebody
success just makes them a little bit
it's like the elephant in the room no
one was
right but it does exist probably on all
so how does how does one through that so
that it's sort of a healthy and being
instead of a bitter jealousy right well
because for my mindset it's always if it
is a jealousy it's always like a good
jealousy where they inspire me to want
to be like make a film as good as that
or something like that is never where I
hate them or resent them for it at night
the court I always think about is I
think on Conan O'Brien's last broadcast
on NBC before he moved on he just said
cynicism is just so ugly you know and
there's no place for it because you know
if you're nice and if you put the work
in you know good things will happen i'm
paraphrasing you know and that's
something i believe like if you know you
put the work in and if you you know if
you just just aren't this negative
person like eventually you know someone
will find you or someone will find your
work you know and it might take a really
long time but i believe that if you just
keep at it and you just have a ton of
attitude you know it'll something will
happen
who knows if you know I know the other
side of it work there are those people
that are in positions or become
successful and are a little bit negative
or you know not the most positive of
people but for me that's just like
living a an ugly life where you know at
the end of the day just I wouldn't be
happy with myself if I was like that
it is something more I think there's
enough i think i've said this before and
one of our radio interviews i think
there's enough room at the top and it's
a very tiny tiny top of the period
pyramid but it's not like the people
around you're all going for the making
the same exact films you know I think
everyone's doing their own thing so if
they make you should be happy for them
because they're you're doing the same
thing they're trying to do and if you
made it you want them to be happy for
you abundance is available forever right
what would you say to yourself in 2004
when you major for short-haul and
looking at your success now which I
think so many people
good way
would you say that
nine years ago what would I say to
myself cooking it at the Gary Kings
career now
don't know maybe it's too big a question
but I would I would tell myself don't
spend as much money on this first
shortcut that's right on myself for sure
but i think the cool thing is it doesn't
feel that long i felt he always feel
like most people i'm sure feel they
always feel like they're learning and
they're always making mistakes and
trying to improve themselves on the next
one so
I don't know I just I feel it's it's
something where it's a question where
I'm almost I can I'm the same person now
except I just technically know more
about you know the film set this you
know that kind of thing I think I just
know I know more but i don't know if
that even I just cause she does my
question was pretty vague I was sort of
conforming it as I was asking you
step so the same person just more
technically aware I think so I mean I
bet it's it's weird because I'm still me
and it's hard to say like this is how
I've changed exactly over these these
nine years
you